Horror movies are full of shocking violence,
terrifying monsters and, occasionally hilarious
bloopers, like these favorites we showed you
last time around.
[Screaming]
“You must be f---ing joking!"
“Over here, over here, over here!
Oh, bollocks!
Okay, just, just, just f--- off!
F--- off!”
[Screaming]
“I actually bit her, I’m sorry.”
But there are plenty more where those came
from!
Here's a look at some more bloopers that completely
change these horror movies.
Fright Night
The defining characteristics of a vampire
have developed over more than a century of
fiction and film.
Everybody knows they sleep in coffins, go
out only at night, and have big fangs they
use to puncture their victims' necks to more
effectively drink their blood.
Countless vampire movies have featured scenes
of vampires dramatically exposing those chompers,
but it loses its dramatic effect and descends
into silliness if, say, those fangs were to
spontaneously fall out of an actor's mouth—as
Christopher Mintz-Plasse discovered while
filming this scene for the 2011 Fright Night
remake.
“Seriously, stay away - oh, f---.
My fang fell out.”
Warm Bodies
Part horror, part comedy, Warm Bodies concerns
a zombified young man stumbling around and
falling in love—and a kid's gotta eat, so
there are plenty of zombie-on-human attack
scenes.
Here, star Nicholas Hoult is supposed to be
going after some human prey, but he surprises
his co-star and crew with some goofing off,
unleashing a loud, boisterous impression of
one of the backwoods torturers from Deliverance—a
very different kind of horror movie.
“It’s mine, m-----------.”
[Scream]
“Squeal like a pig, boy!”
[Laughter]
Hostel: Part II
Eli Roth's second Hostel is maybe even more
gruesome than the first.
So many disturbing things go down: murder,
torture, power saws used as weapons, soccer
played with a human head, and all kinds of
the gory stuff that makes going to the movies
such a magical experience.
And yet the most unnerving thing to ever go
down in the movie, the moment that will linger
with viewers for years to come, is this disturbingly
funny outtake from Hostel: Part II where the
victims don't seem so sad after all:
“This man will show you the way.”
Disturbia
The terror of seeing of a dead body is kind
of at the center of the entire horror genre.
But if you're an actor, seeing festering,
decaying bodies—either dummies or actors
in make-up—day in and day out takes the
sting out of it.
So really, when a snickering Shia LeBeouf
approaches some monstrosity on the set of
Disturbia and kisses it, he's just trying
to jazz up his workday.
[Laughter]
“And, cut!”
Young Frankenstein
Finally, the Mel Brooks classic Young Frankenstein
isn't a horror movie itself, but it does perfectly
skewer old Hollywood horror movies.
Comedian Marty Feldman is one of the film's
many bright spots, portraying Dr. Frankenstein's
faithful assistant Igor as some strange combination
of maniac, pet, child, creep, and vaudeville
performer.
All those parts come into play in equal measure
during this scene, when Feldman gets a little
too carried away and tears apart a prop with
his teeth.
[Growling]
“Stop it!”
“It’s gonna be a long night, so if you
need any help with the girls, don’t hesitate-”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!